okay so Rick and Morty season 6 episode
4 is now out and this feels like a
Halloween Horror entry that has a lot to
impact from it Chuck a block with Easter
eggs movie callbacks and lots of hidden
details we're going to be breaking it
all down throughout this video the
episode opens with a quote from poet TS
Eliot and this has been used as a
framing device for a number of TV shows
and movies if you ever saw the 1994
version of The Stand then you'll know
that it began in a similar manner with a
stanza from The Hollow Men this wasn't
used in every version though and some
networks have added with a quote from
Revelations from the Bible instead this
poem itself is actually taken from
fragment of aegon even the line about
getting the who has it instantly sets a
tone of this horror opening which is
complete with jump scares and nods to
zombie films like Night of the Living
Dead the entry is titled Knight family
and we watches alternate Consciousness
are created for them that carry out
menial tasks in the middle of the night
reminded me a lot of severance and in
case you haven't seen that it basically
involved people that worked at a company
that was so secretive it split its
employees Consciousness into two halves
the first part of this were people who
were always at work whilst the others
lived their lives on the outside
completely unaware of what had just gone
on if you are unlucky enough to be the
half that got put into the work category
then it would feel like you were
constantly there without ever getting a
break or live outside your office it's a
pretty horrifying thought and the
opening of course is inspiration from
more modern day Horrors like Insidious
Paranormal Activity and also Sinister
these took old school horror tropes and
placed them in the American home which
led to a lot of movies like that being
made in the same vein the poem talks
about a nightmare and we see Beth is
unable to sleep due to Jerry's snoring
she tries to count sheep but in the end
just goes downstairs to find Rick doing
sweet sweet crunches damn check out that
washboard yo after learning he's got a
way to carry out tasks in the middle of
the night the rest of the family won in
and they all create a night family the
title itself is named after the American
TV show Night Gallery which was a sort
of sister show to the Twilight Zone
presented by Rod Sterling his hand
series gave us a range of horror scented
episodes great detail in the intro is
that Jerry asks for them to catch him if
he faints and he ends up doing this only
Rick notices it but he still doesn't
help and that takes us in the title
sequence for this part of the video
though I'm gonna beg beg you to what you
don't are you doing a summer on me fine
don't don't like it and don't subscribe
see if I give a [ __ ]
[Music]
people hate that jingle but I like it
anyway most episodes of The Twilight
Zone start off with everything being
bright and Breezy but we slowly watched
his old descended into chaos this is
definitely the case here and we see from
the calendar that the family have had 11
days of Nothing But the good stuff Beth
can play the trumpet summer is an honors
student and Morty has them rock hard ABS
you can bounce a bowling ball off of
there's also lots of nods to Jordan
peele's movie Us in this episode without
film centering around shadow
doppelgangers that came from tunnels
beneath the surface 11 was a number that
constantly appeared in that film with 11
11 tying to a Bible verse in Revelations
as well as the way the family was set
out there's also the fact that it's a
palindrome AKA something that's the same
forward as it is backwards kind of feel
like 11 was chosen for this specific
reason the night people all talk with
croaky voices just like how red and the
rest of the family did Summer soda
becomes this version's red with her
revealing that she's been lying beneath
the surface waiting to come out Rick and
Morty also started a podcast called
absolutely fabulous which is a play on
the British sitcom absolutely fabulous
they have mics that look like share
sm7bs which is pretty much the model
that most people do on the internet
these days including your boy Kevin
spoilers they do a play on the phrase As
Above So Below by saying ABS above so
below and this saying was also used in
us the phrase originates from the
Emerald Tablet and has had many
interpretations over the years with most
believing it talks about the darker side
of things that Lies Beneath the surface
in us it was talking about the
doppelgangers and here it's the reverse
of the family with a knight ones that
come out when the Sun goes down Rick and
Morty are doing ads another guy has sold
out like we all eventually do he refuses
to say Wubba lubba dub dub we see that
night Jerry and Day Jerry have become
pen pals with each other with addresses
all being sleep related puns only a door
like bloody Jerry only would say that
now the pair talk about Tori Amos and
Knight Jerry also asks questions about
the sun though it seems like it's all
going to be fun and games we see see how
horrifying it is for the Knight family
who are all forced to endure these tasks
endlessly like slaves Morty and Rick are
worked at exhaustion and Summer's hands
are destroyed from all the constant
dishwashing the next day she requests
that they rinse the dishes so that
they're easier to clean but Rick being
Rick sees this as a declaration of war
and goes all out to make the job even
harder Rick definitely has no empathy
for others and this is even seen in his
alarm clock which includes birthing a
chicken aging it up so I can wake him up
and then killing it all within a matter
of seconds I think this might be the
first time we've actually been inside of
this room before or at least that I can
remember very messy with a simple bed
and wall full of connecting diagrams and
pictures that has things like his gun
and Mr meeseeks on it realizing the
dishes have been destroyed in protest
Rick travels out of the forbidden zone
which could be a nod to the absurdist
musical comedy you also hear these synth
notes
foreign
scores that John Carpenter would drop in
his movies and in the outer rim we see
as a beast that owes him a favor creates
110 indestructible plates this means you
could take 10 off and it'd still be 100
indestructible in the end Rick has ended
up putting way more effort into this
than he were just running them under
attack for two seconds but it shows how
stubborn that he is now that night the
knife family held Rick down in a sort of
sleep paralysis Manner and they appear
almost like demons over his bed in order
to draw the battle lines this begins a
war between day and night with a lot of
family stripping out all the furniture
summer is made to stay up all night I
love how her suit has Forks in the back
of it so she can't lie down in the
basement she finds that building a giant
some some emulator to extend its range
beyond the house so I'm an ambulator
this reveal came in a way to me that was
similar to the thing in which we
discover the black duplicate is building
a ship below the bunker go to the
calendar which is now replaced the X
with Z's and Counting them up this has
been going on for 23 Days Night swimmers
destroyed their idea of the day being
something fun and she even gets Beth to
burn several day themed DVDs this
includes Independence Day Groundhog Day
and Ferris Bueller's Day Off however she
keeps Talladega Nights showing how the
night must be kept all the others are
made to do the jobs that the nine people
did and Mori does non-stop crunches
whilst Rick and Jerry clean the dishes
when they're put to sleep Jerry leaves a
note for his nightself and he ends up
bringing the others outside the ship is
destroyed and we see their neighbor Gene
the original one got Cronenberg in the
Cronenberg Dimension but the parmesan
one is looking back to normal bet says
his line hold on to your tips
which calls back to this moment from
Jurassic Park hold on to your butts
as they chase through the streets we see
some weird things like kids playing in
the park but but I don't know I don't
know what kids do these days also nice
pun in this sleep in in hey now we also
get this hilarious line by the cop too
step one slowly the night people are
woken up and there's a moment where Rick
Takes the Wheel from summer so she can
fire a shotgun I'm sure this is an odd
to a terminated movie but I'll look
through them all and couldn't find the
clip either if you know get comments
below either way the whole chase scene
reminded me a lot of those movies with
trucks spilling over and them constantly
fighting to wake the others up had me
dying as well when bets started choking
Jerry and we pan down to see that he had
a boner they also be the crap out of
night Jerry even though he's on their
side which a I I co-signed doing that in
the end though they go to call the truce
but Rick still refuses to wash the
dishes and thus the entire night family
end up becoming the main Visions they
now exist in the day and ride up into
the sunset which I this is definitely a
Terminator Easter egg this one isn't it
yeah come on now the credits they show
them going to Bed Bath and Beyond having
a Hawaiian Holiday and watching the
night Museum if you look at the boxes on
the floor you can see they've burned
through the franchise and have watched
two and three as well they celebrate
Chinese his new year go to Paris Beth
plays trumpet on stage and summer gives
Rick a world's greatest Grandpa mug they
live too fast though and not only does
Morty lose his abs but they also run out
of money realizing that the day people
handle all this sort of stuff they
decide to end it all and destroy this
summer emulator which returns them back
to normal however the true horror sets
in when they realize that the Klondike
Choco Taco has been discontinued and
this might even end up becoming the next
Szechuan Source either way that ends the
episode and this was another great one
that's led to this being a really strong
season so far I'm having a complete
blast with it at the moment and even the
more Standalone episodes like this have
been something I've really enjoyed so
yeah great episode and obviously let me
know your thoughts below and I hope
you've been enjoying the breakdown so
far we're in any competition right now
and giving away three copies of dollar
and thunder on the 15th of October and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode we pick the comment at
random on the 15th and the winners are
the last one on screen right now say
that to you then message me on Twitter
at heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of last week's episode
which will be linked on screen right now
you also done a full breakdown of the
latest episode of House of the Dragon so
if you're watching that and definitely
head over there right after this by the
way thanks for sticking through the
video I've been poor to see in the next
one take care peace
thank you
[Music]